le veuille ou non c'est pas de l'alcool
c'est ça fait du bien le bain 1973 dans
l'esprit de beaucoup de français le vin
c'est vraiment pas de l'alcool alors
quand en 1981 professeur de l'inra met
au point sans alcool
c'est le scandale penser qu'une
conspiration en ce moment contre le oui
le malheur c'est que quand elles sont
démontrées il sera trop tard
ce qui motive le professeur de l'inra ce
n'est pas de lutter contre l'alcoolémie
une thématique pas du tout à l'ordre du
jour à l'époque mais bien d'aider les
vignerons à écouler leurs stocks
le procédé d alcoolisées le vin le
procédé mis au point par un chercheur
toulousain permettra-t-il de résorber
les excédents et d'ouvrir de nouveaux
débouchés à la production viticole
on peut se poser la question au vu de
cette découverte
le vin sans alcool à sa création le vin
sans alcool est donc destinée presque
exclusivement à l'export dans les pays
du golfe mais il va tomber dans l'oubli
il fait son grand retour à la fin des
années 80 au moment de la mode des
régimes et du light
après les cigarettes sans tabac les café
sans caféine le beurre sans matière
grasse bientôt le vin sans alcool
principal argument pas d'alcool égale
pas de sucre non nous ne sommes pas dans
une pharmacie mais dans un magasin de
diététique où l'on trouve ce vin sans
alcool depuis un mois mais l'accueil
n'est pas des plus chaleureux ça vaut
pas un petit pot mort
le vin sans alcool tombe de nouveau dans
l'oubli dé il n'a pas dit son dernier
mot
il y a quelques années il tente un
come-back notre rubrique conso tendance
intéresse ce soir ou au vin sans alcool
ou allégé de quelques degrés a si mal
avec ces grosses chaleurs des
viticulteurs tente de séduire une
nouvelle clientèle nous adressons
principalement à trois types de
consommateurs les personnes âgées les
femmes enceintes et musulmans et ce pari
semble fonctionner en 2018 les ventes de
vin sans alcool ont augmenté de 12,3
pour cent sur une annick vin sans alcool
aura donc réussi à trouver sa clientèle
plus de trente ans après sa création
[Musique]